and for the cafe mainly for the huh what
was that most folk here are setting sure
pick it took my but there's a way and I
my mind a changeup inside to win this
election would in olden times leaders
were chosen by something legends say the
toughest once the would-be cap killed
the mire ler uh-huh do this well alright
I'm ready to be a legend you would
there's an old my alert feasting grounds
by in its causeway go there and throw
any kind of meat you've got it and then
wait I'll make sure there's a witness
okay [ __ ] start a passage we're doing
this got me in the water okay [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] please get farther and farther
that says I stream how the [ __ ] that's
fine I guess heck play living on the
edge fine [ __ ] fire get a meadow
signal found with the [ __ ]
that's not my problem okay just keep on
Galan gonna take the claim yes guys got
[ __ ] poisoned us thing a ruthless
trapper huh I don't think I went out
alone [ __ ] is that a [ __ ] rat
chicken Oh boom Shakalaka
alright i stream out a lot socket sucks
yeah what that is this [ __ ] gross
yeah that's sucking goes to [ __ ] too
easy at all like launching
what's that
[ __ ] actually like [ __ ] from afar
okay Imelda
ok [ __ ] I'm just going through yeah
I'm gonna kind of [ __ ] up here
probably should not have swam through
the water radix or something Brad ride
ride out right away
[ __ ] it what is that uh-huh what's in my
third wife hey
Chet [ __ ] her running yeah I can get
a weapon over I don't even remember what
the [ __ ] you think all right hey this
ain't gift wow this kind of [ __ ]
sucks
okay now at that he's your rifle bucket
yes [ __ ] it what is that fish
where my guy
that's the drop mate all right where's
Bob wait for her but either right the
[ __ ] is he
other is ok ok mate how about a mate ok
your pip-boy doesn't sound please say we
get out of here now bets we gotta drop
some mate hey the chopped meat into the
[ __ ] water [ __ ] snake ah [ __ ] down
here chopped meat in the water I did Hey
oh you're my alert
okay this is all you buddy yeah which is
the closest one I'll take I'll go for
this one I guess very good very good he
got him by next mar made into the water
like that
what the [ __ ] is that I take this guy
out that's like a shot a baby I jet
mommy Alec Wayne all right where's
shay-shay
okay batch are you gone for my what yeah
I need a better weapon here's the fat
man which the big boy
come on wow did I [ __ ] actually miss
has mutated come on holy [ __ ] dick
soccer's
uh how you serious bro okay there's
again oh this again where is it come on
I just pop this [ __ ] and go home okay
this one dallin hello ma'am over here
okay okay kind of cute when I walks
awful lot of rap man Santos is here oh
[ __ ] i hate this [ __ ]
that cats kill this [ __ ] okay I'm not
[ __ ] around this tile let's get the
fat ran
Wow why that do like [ __ ] nothing
I cat anything you miss a lodging all
right yeah okay here's teddy that [ __ ]
are you mm-hmm let's go [ __ ]
that was as it's always easy with the
fat man it does when I see people like
struggle like there's actually a ton of
the like missile things why not uncle
people just want same for it to fight
spear
now let me gets my
okay that's kinda I bet these
knuckleheads don't trust you now well
[ __ ] right like a notic folk will be
more talkative I'd even have some more
work for you maybe hit a pitch at the
last plane
XL how patch thank you are the most
peculiar main dish out for her Amish